[Music]
this is
star talk cosmic queries edition this
one titled
the history and science of time-keeping
something we take for granted but uh
some people don't
and they think a lot about it and i got
with me chuck nice jack
hey neil always there for me chuck
that's right
no matter the time long time veteran of
star talk radio
uh and you're my co-host for star talk
sports edition so thanks for making that
happen too
always a pleasure and in spite of
someone who has
no formal athletic background at all
you're actually quite knowledgeable
about sports i'm very impressed um
you know it's easy to be knowledgeable
about something that you've never done
okay no no no it's easy to have opinions
about things that you've never done
well this is true yeah it's easier to be
loud and opinionated about that
exactly right so while i know
something about time keeping and history
uh
everything i know is a tiny subset of
what our guest today knows anthony
evening anthony
welcome back to star talk thank you neil
for putting me on uh having me on
i see what you did there that was fun
being with you
yeah so this is um you've been on at
least this
at least your third possibly fourth time
but it's been a long gap
between these and we've got to have you
on more frequently so i'll make sure
we might say a long time so you're not
only an astronomer you're also
an anthropologist and that's where the
history
dimension of your expertise comes in
you're professor emeritus
of anthropology and native american
studies
at colgate university and author
recently of a book called star stories
constellations and people so
you think a lot about just the
relationship
between humans our culture and
civilization
and the sky above that that's a and
people pay you to do that
well well not anymore because i've just
retired so i'm now on the street selling
pencils
okay and i uh
started i've been trained in
astrophysics a kid peak astronomer of
old
and i got interested in the maya the
maya calendar but just
just to be clear kid peak is the name of
a mountain in
arizona where we have major national
telescopes
on location that we all compete to use
the observing time on them and so uh so
that's where you did your your phd
research
in arizona yeah through the looking
glass as it were
and then i got interested in the mayas
the maya calendar and the question was
how in the world did these people
achieve
such precision and time keeping uh and
get so
engulfed in time measurement if they
were
in fact without a telescope without an
enlightenment without a scientific
revolution
and i ended up spending the rest of my
life up to now
engage in those studies astronomy and
other cultures which
really does teach us to look at the
other
point of view the other culture's point
of view about how
we watch the natural world and astronomy
i mean
because of that this background is
actually quite
rich in cultural diversity
because everyone is looking at the same
thing it's the same sky above all of our
heads
but you come from a different place a
different time a different
valuation of what you see and think and
care about and up comes a whole other
selection of stories that's and so find
a different story
same time i wonder if that would apply
to aliens we think about ep out there
you know and
sometimes we're so darn sure of
ourselves that oh they got to be doing
it the way we do it and anthropology has
something to say about that there are
some lessons you can learn from studying
anthropology about
contact and the other with the capital o
so so so let me ask this other question
then
in anthropology i've i've heard it
characterized i thought quite cleverly
that
when the brits went around
exploring the world cup that's code for
colonizing the world
they would they would come back and
write about it and they would write
about
why where they found was not like them
yeah rather than writing why they are
like the way they are
right so it's a different different sort
of
outlook towards other right so
in your studies how do you
navigate that because you are i presume
american you're america
i am as merkin as president johnson was
okay
so if you've got that then how do you
navigate that when you're trying to
interpret what others have done they've
come along before you and you have
nobody to talk to about it
well let me i am so tempted to give you
a quote
from an anthropologist in fact i'm going
to do it since i'm taking over this show
right now
i happen to have it handy and it's by
edward evans pritchard
which is a rather astute sounding name
he's a british anthropologist working
among the newer people and uer
of south sudan and this is how he sums
up
a thousand pages of his ethnography
and it's about time he says though i
have spoken of time
and units of time the newer have no
expression equivalent to time in our
language
and they cannot therefore as we can
speak of time as though it were
something actual
which passes which can be wasted which
can be saved and so forth
and then he says newer are fortunate
how do you tap into that yeah well the
way i do it is i work with the
anthropologist because to be trained in
astrophysics
what do i know about anthropology so
i've made it a habit of co-authoring a
lot of
works uh by uh under trying to
understand anthropological theory
it's really impossible to tap into
because the past is gone and the ancient
past
before writing the prehistoric past is
very gone
so it isn't easy to do but you have to
work together what so i didn't know that
we have gone
and very gone is that like chuck if
you're bad on stage you're bad or very
bad
there's only there's there's only one
level of bad for me so
yeah you know there's you don't have to
quantify it you don't have to
qualify the bank it's just it it's
there's no level right so so anthony in
time keeping there's some obvious
things like a day all right and a month
and certainly the cycle of seasons for
crops uh beyond that why would anyone
really care
historically well you know i think they
wouldn't
they wouldn't care to be the masters of
time that is to delineate
a system with the uh very very precisely
stringing out all of these events
and measuring them because in most of
these cultures i find the time is the
activity
itself it's not some measurement that
stands apart
there's milking time there's nap time
there's lunchtime there's cocktail time
time is what you do but then wise guys
like
us in the west and the enlightenment had
to come along and take the measure of it
we get it from the greeks that's where
we get our gears from
we mechanize it we build clocks because
we want to see it as something apart
something that's quite apart from all
the events that take place
but in these cultures that i study it's
mostly the activity itself
but isn't it actually the activity
itself in our own culture
but and time is like an observer of that
but not really a participant
yeah that's a great question i think it
well it ask me that question at cocktail
time
right but don't ask it at that time
because because you've seen the the
wrist watches right
and say what time is it and it's it's
beer o'clock have you ever seen that
right well the sun used to be the sun
over the yard arm was the time for
cocktails so it's an astronomical
measurement always comes down to
astronomy
so if we didn't have astronomy how would
we have measures of time
well i would say you stick a stick in
the ground of course then then you're in
astronomy aren't you an astronomer
uh and we know okay so if we grew up on
venus holding aside the fact that we'd
be vaporized
no one would ever see the night sky and
venus has no moon
and it would sort of get light and dark
but very slowly because venus rotates
very slowly
so it seems to me the measurement of
there are places where you can imagine
the measurement of time to be a
pointless exercise
yeah and i think that goes in most
cultures but then why is it that people
like the maya
or the inca got so wrapped up in it and
i think i asked you why
now well the bureaucracy had a lot to do
with it because if you're a bureaucrat
you've got to make maintain control of
the society you've got to have control
of the worker
you've got to have everybody marching to
the same tune so those aztec priests
knew what they were doing when they
invented all of these deities to go with
the names of the days and so on no don't
say that you're telling me
that highly precise time keeping of the
ancients
can be credited to bureaucracy
i'm sorry i don't want to hear that you
know what it kind of makes sense if you
know
if the first guy to invent work and
workers
i can see that might have been the guy
that's just like i gotta have something
like time and you gotta punch a clock
right you in and out of this
out of the temple oh truly you've all
been to the great glockenspiel of marion
plots you know
i only say that once i was there
yesterday but yeah
in munich that clock that huge block on
the uh on the church that goes around
and they bang and they gong and
comedians have made
jokes of it i think probably even chuck
has that is a device
to keep all the workers in order you
have bells that tell the cutters when
they have to cut
the shearers when they have to shear the
packagers when they have
to package and it's damn near like
amazon today you know i mean i think
this
really starts with the industrial age
doesn't it okay so the difference there
is
it's not that you need to know
the time to cut or to pack it's that
someone else wants everyone to be doing
that activity at the same time
bingo so it's the simultaneity
of of culture that requires
organized time timekeeping well it's
yeah it's the
it's the conveyor belt if you will you
know whether you be in the ford factory
in michigan
assuming there's still a ford factory in
michigan this is here you may remember
the i love lucy episode where the yes
with the candy
anyone over 60 knows that episode i
don't know if anybody else does
we're over 80. they got it from charlie
chaplin uh
what was it 1936 film now i'm forgetting
the name of the film but it was a uh
somebody will phone in what it is
he's caught in the gears he's caught in
the wheels of time and you see him seem
to be seeing
seeing him going around getting chewed
up by the gears of the clock
we've seen clips of it yes yeah yeah
yeah so
uh so it it this all this leads us to
think of time in this more mechanized
precise way
whereas for the bulk of human history as
far as i know
uh it never really was that way okay now
that you're retired are you gonna do
what every retired person says
and get rid of clocks in your house well
i haven't quite done that although the
the clock that colgate gave me for my
retirement
lost its minute hand so all i have is
the hour
hand there so i'm going by our timeout
the hour and i think i can see now i
know it's between 12 and 1.
[Laughter]
that's cold your retirement gift broke
that ain't right
that's what and wait they're giving it
to a guy
who's a world's expert on time right
that's wait wait did they really not
like you
sure i must have done something bad with
the football team i failed
that's kind of liberating i kind of like
the idea of just having the
hour because now every hour
is yours you know somebody says call me
at 4 30. like i'm sorry i can't do that
jack i got to ask you have you ever seen
a one-handed clock
no i haven't because they you can see
them they're
they're around in museums uh and i can't
say when the last one was made but this
is certainly more than a couple hundred
years ago
where you just went by the hour and in
the sundial it was
pretty much the same you know i had one
two o'clock i'll see you between one and
two
right and then the sundial doesn't have
a sweet second hand or a minute
right no and it's basically just here
well why don't we meet at the next
quarter moon
you know we'll see at the next quarter
moon well it was that tuesday or
wednesday
it doesn't matter you know we'll just uh
when when powhatan
attacked the colonists in virginia he
did it by
regulating the tribes to come at the
last quarter moon i mean that's well
established
in in local history in virginia and they
they seem to get it right they be
they beat up on the colonists by uh well
some of them got there a day early some
a day late
but a quarter moon is is pretty that's
as precise as you right
yeah you get it can you get it to the
day i know a lot of
my students can't get it to the day you
ask them to time it
some of them will get tuesday some will
get thursday most would get wednesday
and it would work out but uh you gotta
have a little leeway
i think so that movie we just uh
researched that it's called modern times
with yeah
thank you thank you yeah very good it's
in one of my books but
i forget and how many books have you
written i own most of them i think but
not this latest one 30 35 depends on
what editing
i've edited or written that's what i
have my secret is that what's about to
collapse on your head behind you in the
scene there oh
well those are op books other people's
you know
people no doing research
you're all pulling around if you want to
see it go to the other one oh it's very
beautiful
that's my
so chuck you so we got questions from
our uh patreon members i think
yes we do is that right so i thought
that was it i didn't know we had
questions
no yeah yeah no you know we're not
letting you go that easy okay
it's like i'm done i'm spent i'm spent i
can't
i can't do no more that's great
all right okay let's jump right into it
as a matter of fact uh
all of our uh questions have come from
our community of patreon patrons
and so um if you are listening to this
and you are not a patreon patron
i encourage you to do so so that uh your
questions can take priority
so it's just not that i mean patreon if
those who don't know
it's not just because people feel
charitable as you might know
for npr or pbs it's like they want
something in return
you you support us and we do things for
you we'll do
that and there's a whole there's a whole
list of stuff right and you attend our
parties and stuff
it's like any marriage okay
all right all right here we go here we
go here we go here we go here we go here
we go
um hello neil and anthony
and chuck we use atoms but who
who is this oh i'm sorry this is john
david newman hey john
okay thank you john for having a
pronounceable name chuck
why did you say why do you think i said
wait a minute hold on hold on
i had to i had to scroll down the list
to get to something that i could
pronounce
what's that what you're picking no you
can't pick questions
if you can pronounce their name okay all
right that is wrong i won't do that
anymore
okay i just wanted to start off with a
pronounceable name john david newman
uh he says hey neil hello anthony hello
chukka we use
atoms for the most accurate time keeping
could an atom change its rate of
vibration and if so
would we even know if it did ooh
great question we gotta wait till we
come back ah
damn it let's take a quick break uh
i love that question uh and when we come
back more of star trek cosmic queries
with
time astronomy anthropological expert
anthony aveni return
we're back start talk cosmic queries
and measurement and culture and history
and it's all there chuck good to have
you chuck you you're tweeting these days
at chuck nice comic yes check nice
comment you have to tell people you're a
comic this is lame
uh no i mean listen i don't want there
to be any doubt
it's like should i laugh at this oh it
says oh yes
i mean listen i i look at it this way um
sometimes if if you go to medical school
and you have a practice you put
md at the end of your next reminder just
to remind
people okay that i'm just not
i'm not going to answer right i'm not
just joe johnson
okay that's a good answer good answer so
anthony we left off with a great
question here we are anchored on atomic
time for the last
five decades at least and if that's the
measure
how do we know that adam is not messing
with us
yeah well i want to thank johann for a
brilliant question
or was it john i think it was john
that's john yeah the last i heard
we were keeping time by the vibrations
in the cesium adam
to something close to 10 to the minus 15
seconds
and i'm sure as john would know that's a
one over ten with 15 zeros after it
so that's a quadrillionth of a second
yeah i mean if
if if a second is the distance from the
earth to the moon the femtosecond
is about the width of one of neal's
hairs that i'm looking at right now so
pretty small uh
neil has some pretty luxurious hair yes
it's pretty thick i gotta tell you
you may notice if you're seeing my image
i didn't use one of my own hairs
and use your hair it's singular we can
only make the measurement as accurately
as we can make it and if the
cesium atom wants to mess with us
there's no way we're going to know until
we can go beyond
femto femto femtoseconds and so we need
something
that's what happened with us with
astronomy when we thought that the
movement
of the sun and the moon and measuring
the sun's transit
at noon time was accurate enough earth's
rotation yeah but it's not
it's not accurate enough and that's why
we went to the cesium atom so who knows
where we end up
so we will so we won't know anything
about whether the atomic vibrations
change
until we find something more accurate
than it to hold it accountable and
that's the nature of science isn't it
you never tend to have a theory that
can't be
changed or uh updated and so it's a good
example of how science operates
right but just to be clear that changing
is to make it more precise
not to make it something completely
different just to be clear when we're on
to something we're on to it
yeah and then we got it chuck you're
going to say something well i was just
going to say i'm
that makes me think that all
measurements then are
subject to that same principle every
single measurement
you've ever made with height you name it
wow okay
god now now i don't believe in anything
anymore
yeah yeah so chuck how tall are you was
it ah that's great
all right give me another one all right
wow what a great question what a great
answer guys thanks
okay here we go this is uh sam o'neil
and i'm i'm not looking for
names just happen to be that way hello
geniuses
and
that's not what he said i don't know he
did
i added that in okay okay
uh samantha here and i run i
run and use kilometers instead of miles
to measure my workouts firstly because
kilometers are shorter
and that allows me to believe that i
have less work to do while i'm an
individual
kilometer and secondly you clock up more
kilometers and feel happier about the
number of kilometers you've
run my question is if we adjust the
scale of time
and make years shorter so that the
average life expectancy
age number becomes higher what
psychological
impact would that have on the human race
whoa what a what a profound question
um and uh couched in a humble brag
of our physical fitness
but uh if i if i instead of living to be
an average of 80 i live to be an average
of a hundred
and sixty forget whatever the
measurement is does the number alone
have an effect on who i am and how
anthony
yeah well i think uh samantha i don't
know if you're old enough to have
remembered the
move uh in the 80s to try to kilometrize
miles and change to the uh
metric system in the united states
yeah was it in the 80s earlier no 70s in
the 70s under
president carter yeah it was under
carter uh it didn't happen but i mean if
it did we'd be
we'd be talking different numbers now my
wish
has always been to get together with
elon musk and go to mars
and live there and start a colony and
live for thousands and thousands of
years
because because mars revolution period
around the sun
is closer to two years than to one and
then i'd only be half my age
and my kids and their kids and their
kids kids kids kids kids
would then come to think the way
samantha likes to think about kilometers
they would come to think about years she
wanted that
so wait wait so that's the reason why
you want to go to mars
not to save the species not for science
wow it's my own selfishness i want a
number that tags me younger
i don't want to be an octonono do
decorating
okay so here's my my reply to both of
y'all
okay so the solution to this is
we adjust the human genome so that you
never die
and therefore you don't have to worry
about how many years you just counted
for your age
oh god that sounds awful adjust your
genome yeah yeah
that fixes that problem in a different
way
well it does but that creates a whole
another set of problems
you know that like the fact that we
would never die
i mean that would change your psychology
of life
completely yeah well can i tell you a
quick story here
okay and just into the psychology of
this yeah right
all right i was this a slightly long
story and i
hate doing this because i want to really
get questions but it's directly
it is directly related okay uh i have
never been picked for jury duty
i always get kicked out after the voir
dear part
because they ask me questions and they
never like my answers okay yeah
i'm the same way except i'm racist okay
so that
that'll get you out all right so
that's not the reasons why they so i'm
there
and i made it far enough like
15 people to hear the details of the
case
all right were read to us so i said man
maybe i'll get on a case this time
and so the judge reads the particulars
of the case
and here is what both sides agree and
the
the defendant was found uh in possession
of cocaine
um 3 000 milligrams of cocaine on the
upper
west side of manhattan and they were
found by an undercover cop
and then so this was done and then i and
they saw there any questions about these
details
and i raised my hand said your honor why
did you say
3 000
milligrams of cocaine that's just
three grams which is
you know barely the weight of a penny
so i i why did you say that well oh
that's what it's written here but
well it sounds like you want it to feel
like more drugs than it actually is and
while i'm saying this
the whole rest of the potential jurors
were looking at me
and looking and so and i was out on the
street 10 minutes later
because and i might have contaminated
quote contaminated just by
just by undoing the units of measure
they're using to make something sound
bigger
right yes so here's my two here's my two
takeaways from that story
one neil degrasse tyson the only guy in
america
trying to get on a jury
uh right and and two neil degrasse tyson
the drug dealer's best friend
[Laughter]
i didn't think about i was just thinking
about the honesty of the read no you're
sorry so anthony that was all
about psychology there yeah and i like
the way you say 3
000 which is the same way carl sagan
used to say
billions
[Laughter]
yeah it's so funny you know it's so
funny we had a conversation once neil
and we were talking about the metric
system
and how the only people in america who
use it are drug dealers
yes yes drug dealers are the best drug
dealers only people who know the metric
system
they should have been the ones training
americans and we'd all be metric
fluid today there you go all right give
me another one
all right let's go to dustin fenwick uh
who says
i've been listening to star talk for
some time now and many times i've heard
you dr tyson talk about how other life
forms out of the universe may see human
beings in a similar fashion
to how we see chimpanzees so
if that is true with regard to
intelligence yes
yes um is it possible that aliens
visiting earth may have a completely
different concept and understanding of
time
than we do and what impact do you think
this discovery could have on humankind
and our understanding of the universe so
i mean
there's an assumption in that question
that there's a contact made
and then we understand that they
understand time differently
than we do right and that's of course
the theme to the
the movie from a few years ago arrival
anthony did you see a rival
yes i did and i was going to mention
that yeah so go ahead just reflect on
so so chuck this is exactly the center
piece
of the difference between this alien
visiting
intelligence and us so anthony why don't
you take us there well i'm thinking of
the hepto the hepto
digital people who had seven digits
rather than
the usual 10. yeah basically tentacles
they were like
a pods i think they call them right also
ursula leguin's
work comes to mind there was an american
masters on her she wrote a book
back in the 60s about a hypothetical
base 12
culture that we evolved into a base 12
culture so
all the expression of our numbers and
all of our mathematics is totally
different and has to be re-deciphered
that doesn't get to the cognitive part
of
dustin's question um but
it does i think at least it allows us to
think that there are other ways of
cognizing reality but okay obviously
it's it's fiction and it's a novel
but is there any uh credence
based on your understanding of the
diversity of human understanding of time
that this could be a real thing out
there well yes there are
well wait for tell us what it was first
of
all
in borneo which uses a language
and uses cognitive elements wherein
there is no past and no future
there's no past present and future
everything
happens all at once it's all happening
at once now wait a minute wait a minute
you're saying i i had breakfast this
morning i know that was in the past
i know this wonderful session on star
talk is going to be over soon
and then i've got to wash some clothes
but uh but
imagine having a brain that doesn't
think that way
doesn't think of a past or a future but
everything is in the present and it's
reflected in the language and the tenses
there are no tenses i can't because
tense is to distinguish best
in future times it's time dependent and
i can't fathom that and
but i know chuck is waving his hand so i
bet he can no i can't i was
i was trying to figure out like where do
you it's just like so i had breakfast
this morning now and
so i'm going to the doctor now now and
then i'm going to have dinner later now
and i'm getting married now
but you know who who is to say why we
think that way but
we do not as a homo sapiens not even as
homo sapiens because we're talking about
a
a brand of homo sapiens who do not share
our thoughts about past present future
but remind us what how the aliens
thought in
in the movie arrival
well how they yeah that's right i think
the past
was conflated with the future was it yes
right so so if i remember correctly
there was a
um time was a loop it was a little so
that yes so there was no
uniform direction of the future in the
past
now that's interesting because i think
whoever wrote that must have had some
good understanding of anthropology
because
many cultures in the world conceive of
time cyclically
we conceive of it linearly we imagine
all of the events that happen
that we experience are like so many
beads on a wire
and then judeo-christian theory
and ideas teach us that that that that
line
or band or wire is tilted upward because
those beads move toward
the apocalypse toward the great
confrontation toward the center
so it needed a linear construct in order
for there to be an apocalypse but how
can we imagine living in a world
where time is not linear well we can say
well okay there's the spring and summer
and fall and of course tomorrow follows
today
and the movement of the sun around the
earth if we would have it that way
which is cyclical is cyclical but still
time is linear as we see it isn't it
yeah because next year is still
different from this year
exactly right maybe maybe a good model
would be a helix
you know a loop that goes around and
then ascends
as it goes i see so it loops but doesn't
exist so you get the best of both
worlds yeah you get the looping of time
and the forward movement you get
progress fitting in don't you we love
progress
because as time goes on it gets bigger
and things get better we saw that in the
inauguration speech of
president biden that's going to get
right so i love that concept so what
you're saying is
if you live in a world where there is no
for lack of a more creative way to think
this technological progress
then next year is identical to this year
yes yes
so why distinguish them with strong
language about with numbering the years
and and having new year's celebration
that seems
all artificial now and it comes from a
belief in the idea of progress
which not every culture believes in
chuck i'm sorry i interrupted you no i
was going to say what
what you just sparked to me is the the
the uh um
the interest in whether there are
cultures that
mark time just be just from events
so if you're not looking at progress as
a demarcation of
time or if you're not looking at things
in a linear fashion
then maybe it's just this happened
yeah and that becomes time
so it's just a sequence of events
without concern about the duration
right of time between them duration is
the key yeah right
right right right we got to take a quick
break we're going to come back
fascinating
and keep this going i'm living it okay
this is star talking
apotheosis time
anthropology astronomy all of the above
we're back star talk cosmic queries time
culture anthropology anthony of any
anytime you say those other few words
anthony is right
behind the door right ready to walk in
to straighten things out
anthony thanks for being on star talk
for me
you need to now you're retired you know
you got we got to help you out here
uh retired for how many years had
colgate it was just a couple
just just i fit in two years
a couple years couple years ago i don't
keep time anymore
you got it okay chuck give me some more
questions because
we're in cosmic queries mode yes uh
let's go to uh ben butler who says
uh hello neil doctor of any um uh
my question is how
are time zones affected with the keeping
of time do they have
any part to play with time keeping or
just a way to tell
time in different countries sorry if
this sounds
silly no no anthony what's up with time
zones
why doesn't the whole world have one
time thank you ben
for your question um why don't we all
have one time
blame it on the railroads uh blame it on
the high speed of travel not now but in
the
19th century when you could step on a
train and go from
new york to uh cleveland in a matter of
less than a day
well we regulate our time of course by
where the sun is
so you've got time in the station
regulated by the sun
and then once you get on the train
you're in a different place so we've got
time on the train and time off the train
you have to have some agreement about
what the time is going to be
so we all get together and say hey let's
share
the time of the 15th 30th 45th 60th and
so on multiples of 15
meridians now where i live so these are
longitude lines
longitude lines that happens to be a
longitude line that passes near albany
somewhere so i'm west of that time
so i got to set my clock back and the
people who are out on cape cod
have to set it the other way and we all
agree to that
uh just to be clear so you
and everyone in cape cod are in the same
time zone
but you are west and east of each other
which means the sun is not in the same
part of the city
if we if we stuck a stick in the ground
and made the sundial
we would get a different result for the
time from each other
and so you're saying rather than it be
noon for you
at a different time than noon for cape
cod yeah you want to agree on a noon
even no matter what the sun is doing
right so we want to have what you might
call a mean
noon or an average noon and that's what
zone time is and of course
then you have to have some place to
begin the day
and you can run it
[Laughter]
well you begin it out actually in the
middle of the the other side
islands in the middle of an ocean where
uh it doesn't matter too much whether
it's sunday or monday uh but we've been
forced into that because
of high speed travel and that all
started with the railroads
wow wow that is great
that's where the big ben clock got
started too all right keep going chuck
all right steve solomon says hello neil
hello anthony hello
chuck and the whole team i'll bet chuck
can pronounce my name
okay thanks buddy um
[Laughter]
my question is does the arrow
what's his name again what's his name
his name is steve solomon
steve solomon okay yeah all right uh
my question is does the arrow of time
always point
forward for us ugly giant
bags of mostly water
[Laughter]
speak for yourself
now he says however the math
supports time in both directions
indeed it does so for most things yes
yeah from so
i mean so if the math works can can can
we find
a physical representation of the math or
can that happen well steve
uh i've had two steve solomons in my
teaching career you may be one of them
both of them were wise guys but it's a
good time
the arrow of time because teachers never
forget students
never forget one of them i flunked out
and he came back when he was in his 20s
but
did very well and filmed them but anyway
that's enough about me you know i think
steve's question depends on what we want
to conceive of as reality
you know we can define an arrow of time
that goes either way but the way we've
got it down
that arrow goes forward from the past
into the future
unless you can get a time machine joke
you know and make the time go backwards
travel faster than the speed of light
this is the reality we have devised
to understand how events take place in
the world
sounds like i'm slipping away on the
question but i'm really not what do you
think oh
let me see if i understand what you just
said all right so you're saying
because we experience the world
with an arrow of time going forward all
of our language and everything we've
developed about
our thoughts and civilizations orbits
that so to speak
and so we don't need to reckon
with an hour of time that moves the
other way but if there were such a thing
then we'd deal with that right and and
and things would
break before you let go of them right
that would be the order of events
but how neat it is that we've invented
mathematics
so as to deal with that and that opens
up our imagination to all kinds of
possibilities that we wish we could
experience there are limitations in this
universe
and you'd see a scrambled egg
unscrambled and go back into a shell in
the shell
and we would see that and say that's
normal yeah i could but and i can see it
on a video i can do a video you know
yeah
so so things that move backwards in time
that look irreversible
only because that's our life experience
yeah not not and
that had been our life experience than
cracking an egg and dropping it into a
pan would say oh my gosh how did you do
that
well you know neil we ought not to get
too serious but we also devised the law
of entropy
the second law of thermodynamics you
know that you're going to
always going to go for from organization
toward disorganization
but then we defined what organization is
and what this organization is
so so dependent on how we live and
that's the anthropology of it that's the
anthropology of it
and i like einstein's was it einstein's
quip um
motion no time is defined to make motion
look simple
yeah wow is that deep that's great
yeah yeah all right so chuck let's do
lightning round because we've been
luxuriating on these other questions ah
who cares i like it i mean okay
so anthony pretend you're on the evening
news and you're interviewed for two
minutes
and so it's it's uh sound bite answers
okay let's go
okay guys here we go this is roman
precup
precup okay roman says this since the
earth is slowing down
how long will it take until we need so
many leap
seconds that we will not
there will not be a rule that a minute
has 60 seconds so
you got to put so many seconds in that
just change the whole example change the
whole system
yeah yeah what's up with that stay less
than a million years what would you
think uh
neil yeah so it's it's tiny right now
and we're doing good with the leap
seconds i mean i we're hanging on
with anthony how we've had 25 or so leap
seconds yeah we have
50 years so leap second every couple of
years okay um so
when does it reach just where we're
actually
uh taking water in a bucket
and you know becomes that well you know
what we'll do is we'll do leap hours
and we'll do what we did in the in the
gregorian calendar reform we just
whacked off ten days
knock out ten days and tomorrow today's
the fourth
tomorrow would be uh 14 you know
yeah so so the corrections might become
greater than leap seconds leap minutes
leap hours leap days okay um interesting
so so just to be clear from the
the what do we call the people who are
experts at timekeeping
not metrologists chronologists
chronologists
from the chronologists i've spoken with
they don't want to change the definition
of the second
because so much anchors on that they'd
rather just add more seconds into the
day
because you could just make the second a
little longer right and that that
absorbs it eats
every correction you'd ever need to make
to it and put you in motion for another
million years or so
but we have so much depending on that
definition we're keeping it well we
used to have roman numerals we don't
have much left of those anymore
no yes we do for the super bowl
the last bastion but not 10
and 50. did you know that that super
bowl 10 was not x it was 1 0.
yeah and 50 i think that the reason why
they didn't have it for 50
good you knew that uh i wrote a whole a
lot about this
they tweeted about it because i when we
were at super bowl 49
right which is a lot of roman numerals
so stacked there i said to myself hmm
if we go to super bowl 50 and all of
that just becomes an l
l then it's just super bowl right you'd
have two l's
super bowl and then an l and you
wouldn't be able to parse that
so and sure enough they made it and you
know when they went from nine to ten
they didn't like the x because people
were googling up whatever googling up
was in those days
and finding nasty websites you know
xxx websites interesting so what was
super bowl 30.
that would really get you in there
why are all my searches for super bowl
10 ending up with a guy delivering a
pizza
so much for the lightning round yeah
right so yeah anthony you failed that
first test
okay let's try them again all right so
here here we go this is robert
weaver and robert says good afternoon
if space-time is able to be bent by
gravity assuming humans could
ever control that bending could we
travel across
folded and then unfolded parts of space
and time
instantly would we have passed to
either side okay and then he just goes
on to give you a uh
uh more examples of that and then he
says hey thank you guys both of you for
inspiring us
p.s chuck i like you too okay so
okay that's the chuck amendment
exactly right you know i'll take that
though
you know maybe i'm not inspiring but at
least i'm liked
so anthony let me ask let me broaden
that a little bit so our modern sort of
scientific
culture tells us about relativity and
the curving of space time
and the distortion of time and is that
just our
culture sense of time and then when we
die off or in the apocalypse there'll be
some other one and then we'll just be in
the
in the in the in the archives of how
people thought about time
i'll raise you one by suggesting that
all of geometry
is part of our culture because we are
greek
the very idea of thinking about geometry
whether it's euclidean or non-euclidean
is
a western idea show me
one evidence of geometry in any culture
other than one that came through the
middle east in greece
and i'll give you a dollar and of course
the bending of space and time requires
geometry to see it to calculate with it
to predict with it
as far as we know as far as we know we
are talking in our own language
the answer to robert's question is show
me how to do it
but you can sure do it in your mind but
i can't imagine an operational way of
doing it
and i can't even imagine conceiving of
it in any other way than geometrical
so it's part of our culture wow so it
might be that i hadn't thought about
this
if we did not have geometry as our in
our tap roots
we may have never ultimately arrived at
relativity yeah
you know how the story goes we don't
have time to do it but i talk about it
in
more than one of my books the whole
chaos metros the measurement of the city
measuring the city is where this starts
and in the greek city
they had orbs they even aristotle even
talks about this
orbs of citizens who cluster around the
center who orbit around the center
and then the intellectual thought turned
to ordering the universe above the way
they were ordering the city so the whole
idea of geometry starts in the city
and then moves to the sky and then moves
on to einstein
wow that's anthropology that's why i do
the impact
western anthropology yeah very good
all right chuck keep it coming keep
going here we go
this one um uh
this is from nick stark hmm sounds like
a uh
an alter ego for a superhero or tony
stark's song
uh hello dr tyson could you explain one
of your
uh most favorite oeds
or peds related to space-time
or just physics in general so do you
have a
a partial differential equation that you
actually
lay down at night and cuddle up
idea do you have a do you have an
ordinary
differential equation that you have half
frames
i thought it was either that or maybe
some kind of disease of the intestine
that he wanted i know right did you do
you were afflicted by the what's
by the way i just want to say nick stark
sounds like the name of a uh a detective
in a noir film
nice you have that too that's right it's
got that ring it has that ring yeah it's
got that fast talk in yeah
it does yes exactly it's just like she
came to me and i
yeah and you got the coat and the head
it was a rainy night when she walked in
i know it was trouble
wait so i i would just say just so
people in calculus their equations
what one of the great glories of
calculus is it enables you to calculate
using variables that are changing
simultaneously with each other
and this is in track basically
intractable using any other kind of math
that preceded calculus and so there's a
kind of
equations that exist in calculus that
allow you to just
pry forward watching something unfold
with multiple forces and multiple
variables
changing at the same time and with these
you have what are called differential
equations
that do that the partial differential
equation pdes these sorts of things
so my favorite of these is the set of
equations
that came out of einstein's work that
describe the curvature
of space and time and it is this simple
equation
it looks simple but the calculations are
hard that
tell you what how much mass and energy
will then give you how much curvature on
the other side
and so for me that that's for me anthony
do you have any favorite
well you know i got an a minus in diff
eq i was a math minor in a physics major
so i do know well what you're talking
about chuck he's on the first name
differential question that's the
nickname basis
that's beyond first name basis yeah okay
that's like nickname for your math
that's like i call barack obama barry
[Laughter]
despite working with these two silly
dudes i'm going to try to put the
anthropological twist
on this because i think what nick is
talking about
is conflating a whole large number of
concepts into one
magic equation the maya did it with a
magic number
two six zero they had
everything that they ever measured or
even submeasured multiples or parts of
two
six zero they had the period of mars
measured according to two six zero it
happens to be three times two six zero
they had the period of venus the synodic
period of venus
measured that way in fact it's in the
ratio of eight to five
with the period of venus and the year
and a whole bunch of other things
i know you're dying to know what 260 is
well it's 13 times 20
20 is the number of digits on a human
body uh
that is digits and fingers in total and
uh 13 is the number of layers of heaven
two
six zero now this is where you guys are
all going to get really serious when i
tell you this you're going to drop your
jaws
because it's the jaw-dropping number
gestation period
of the human female now i know that
answer isn't going to satisfy a person
who's into differential equations
but the important thing is that you
always look for
expressions numbers equations
that can envelop the largest number of
phenomena that you see and for the maya
it was the gestation period of the human
female the gestation period being the
mother of all numbers
i call it well let me tell you uh i'm
just going to say
that that was a very elegant answer in
the face of
our being silly i'm i am so impressed
that was that was said he put he pulled
that one out of the trash i mean that
was
that was incredible that was incredible
they pulled our stuff out of the trash
dusted it off
yes that was listen you i bowed to you
sir
that was amazing well to be honest i
pulled it out of my butt but that that
would be me
wait wait anthony i thought isn't the
human gestation period slightly longer
than 260. i'm thinking up north
56.7 but what's a 3.5
among people who don't yeah i thought it
was longer than that i'm going to look
on that i'm
going to get back to you yeah check me
out i'll check you out
you uh i'll bet you the name of an
asteroid
a little shorter but i could somebody
will have the answers of course
instantly
yeah yeah i think it's i think it's up
closer to 280 days unless the mayan had
different
gestation periods from other people that
certainly can be well let me just tell
you this
after three gestation periods i know
that the post-suffering time is 18 years
okay let me just say that calculated
okay so anthony you come back with that
multiple and tell us what you got
with an excellent postpartum on your
porch
all right we got to cut we got to
actually quit there no
oh all right dude anthony of any
on our website anthony f of any dot dot
com yeah anthony dot com ed chuck always
good to have you
always a pleasure this has been star
talk cosmic queries
thanks again to my friend and colleague
uh
now retired anthony benny i'm neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
beating you to keep